a great big story we've been playing the
mobile game clash of clans our favorite
character is the balloon flown by a
skeleton who dropped bombs on enemies
from above welcome everyone to
Shreveport Bossier Louisiana and the
2017 Red River Balloon Rally over the
coming days some of the best hot-air
balloons will be competing in the sky
overhead though we decided to find
someone who dropped things out of
balloons in real life and we found this
side my name is red hearts cool I'm a
competitive hot air balloon pilot
competitive hot air ballooning is an
accuracy competition we have Waypoint to
fly into and we drop a marker and it's
closest to that Waypoint is the best
score my sister Kate she navigates to
the targets driving on the ground she
reads all the winds with a little helium
balloon because we're usually coming in
from high altitude and we want to drop
down on the deck because you're more
accurate with your throws from 50 feet
high and 500 feet high you think hitting
X's is harder than trying to hit a large
defensive structure like a with your
tower absolutely the x's are only one
meter by one meter so it wasn't our be
pretty simple to run through when you
get down and you're dead center of that
X your heart starts racing like you have
buck fever and that's what really makes
it
I was basically born into the sport and
when you start that young it's just
normal from day one
my father's flown since the late 70s
when he bought it balloon my parents
don't have any money but it turned out
to be the best things ever happened our
family it's a good hobby to bring us
together and we hope to continue this
evolve you came
[Music]